yesterday was a super interesting media
criticism day we had guests on both
fox news and newsmax call out fox news
and newsmax for their perpetuating
lies on the air later we'll look at
newsmax but let's start with fox news
these are really really good clips
randy weingarten is a lawyer a labor
activist labor leader
president of the american federation of
teachers member of the afl-cio
fox news's martha mccallum brought randy
weingarten on to talk about
critical race theory being taught in
schools this segment is not going to be
about critical race theory i just did a
whole segment two shows ago
on critical race theory you can find it
on the friday podcast or on youtube so
this is not the topic today
that was the topic of the segment we're
going to look at and check out how randy
just goes right at fox while being
interviewed by martha mccallum
for them spreading misinformation and
martha mccallum doesn't like it
big believer in celebrating diversity
in action and actually looking at and
helping
look at people's lived experience but if
you're
really talking about misinformation now
martha and i hope you are
i really would hope that fox would
really look at what happened in this
election
and how we can because every social
studies teacher is wrestling with this
discern fact from fiction we have to do
that
yeah we have well we have a president
president biden
uh was elected in 2020 i i think that
all of that is
is quite clear um so i'm not sure why
you you know are so concerned with with
that
part with that particular moment in
history every election is significant
nobody is hiding anything under any
rocks here but
i but i do want you know the fact that
you have two martha mccallum is just
so confused about why randy weingarten
would bring up telling the truth about
the election oh
i don't know maybe because of the months
of spreading and inviting guests to
spread disinformation about the election
which partially played a role in getting
things to the fever pitch that
culminated on january 6th with the trump
riots maybe that has something to do
with it martha
and then this is really great even
though martha mccallum
immediately tries to start talking over
randy weingarten
in her next opportunity randy comes
right back
and does the same thing on the topic of
vaccination reporting and this time
martha mccallum gets more upset i would
hope
fox says to all these people that don't
want the vaccines
that think there's a problem why don't
you
and i do things together to get
our kids back to school this is what we
need to do we have to stop the
misinformation
we have to stop the disinformation
as you know you know as you know
uh many of those students were back
without being vaccinated and the cdc
said it wasn't required for teachers or
students to be vaccinated to go back to
school
so children are a separate issue every
family across america is going to make
that decision
about their children we know that these
are going to be widely available for
them which is great so people have that
option
that indignant attitude is just too much
fox hosts get
absolutely exasperated when they are
confronted by guests
for what fox news does says and puts out
on the airwaves and we've covered those
incidents before
she got defensive really quickly and
randy weingarten
really getting under martha mccallum's
skin there and if you're watching these
clips
rather than just listening you may
notice the facial expression
change just instantly on martha
mccallum's face when the call
out starts to happen if guests did this
more regularly on fox news
i think fox would have to change its
approach maybe they'd have to switch to
pre-recording interviews to prevent this
maybe they wouldn't even have these
guests on i don't know if that's better
right to some to some degree
it's good to have people who talk sense
on fox news it might pierce someone's
filter bubble or echo chamber i don't
know i don't know
but that's kind of my question like is
there a downside to this presumably it's
the guests won't be invited
back maybe fox news will further even
limit the voices that are allowed
on the channel but um if guests started
doing this more regularly i think it
would be absolutely great and amazingly
this was not the only instance of a
guest
calling out the network on that network
yesterday
this example was from fox news i now
have one
to look at from newsmax one of our
sponsors purevpn is giving you 47
off a one-year plan which comes out to
less than six bucks a month
purevpn makes you anonymous online and
you can trust them they're the only vpn
with an always-on
third-party audit verifying that your
internet activity is not being logged
purevpn keeps you safe from hackers
prevents you from being spied on by your
isp
social media companies government
surveillance it lets you stream
shows and movies that aren't available
in your country
purevpn is super fast with over 6500
servers and you can use it on all of
your devices with 10
devices logged in at the same time you
can try it for a week for just 99 cents
and you'll get 47
off a one-year plan which is less than
six bucks a month when you go to
davidpakman.com
vpn the link is under this video and
you'll even get an
extra additional 10
off when you use the code pacman